ماذا تستنتج من كلماته، مثير للاهتمام للغاية ما هو عليه
قال عنه
قطر هي المرة الأولى التي يقف فيها رئيس الوزراء أمامها
الكاميرات تهاجم كاتر لكونها المضيفة
وفي تمويل حماس، تعتبر قطر الوسيط الرئيسي
وفي المفاوضات من أجل إطلاق سراح المختطفين، أعتقد أنه لو روش
الحكومة تريد معالجة القاطرة والهجوم عليها أو
لا، وله كذا وكذا اعتبارات لا شيء
والذي من المفترض أن يتم في الخلف مثل ذلك في الحفلة
الصحفيون يجيبون على سؤال هو الشيء الذي ينبغي أن يكون
أكثر جدية قليلاً على خلفية العلاقة المستمرة
التفوق على قطر الوسيط الرئيسي في الأمر
وهذا أيضًا أمام مصر يوجد صدع بالفعل في الواقع هناك صدعان
قضايا تؤرق مصر هذه الأيام.
وإسرائيل هي إحدى المحاولات لتحميلهم المسؤولية
كامور لتأخير إدخال فول الصويا الإنساني إلى غزة
وما يضرهم هو الموضة في الرأي العام في العالم العربي
ورئيس مصر نفسه السيسي خاطبكم بصوته
في الأسبوع الثاني، ستكون المشكلة في الفعل
السيطرة على محور تحية ابن فيلادلفيا
مصر إلى قطاع غزة هذا الأسبوع قال مسؤول مصري كبير
ومن الواضح في صوته أن خطوة من هذا النوع ستكون خطيرة
بشدة وجدية العلاقات بين الدول
تعتقد الحكومة أن السعر في الوقت الحالي باهظ الثمن للغاية
أعدوا ابني وجميع المختطفين الـ 136 الآخرين
المنزل أعتقد أنه لا يوجد ثمن، وإذا كان طفلا
له أنه لن يعتقد خلاف ذلك لا يوجد شيء
وهو ما يؤلم اليوم ويجعل فرصة العودة أبعد
المختطفون يعودون سالمين من المئات والحملات
الآلهة التي ترفع السعر تجلس سنوار اليوم
في القبو يشاهد استوديوهات التلفزيون وفقط
ينتظر
الإلهام يأتي للعائلات ويخبرهم ألا يستسلموا
المطالبة بعدم تضخم الأسر في العالم أن الدولة
كبارهم مرتين، مرة واحدة على شيف في أكتوبر
ومنذ السابع من أكتوبر، لم يعد الأمر مثل الاختلاط
تنتهي القصة هنا، ونحن نستعد هنا أيضًا
لقد عادوا إلى إسرائيل، ونعم، تالي، ثم في إسرائيل، لم يعودوا أيضًا
هل تعتقد أن هناك سببًا للاحتفال، أليس كذلك؟ السلحفاة لم تخرج
التصرف بطريقة لا تتصرف بها إسرائيل بكلمة واحدة
منع الأشياء التي لا تمنعها إسرائيل من كلمة إلا
وما زالوا في إسرائيل يعتقدون أن هذا ليس خيرًا مطلقًا
أننا من الناحية الدولية والمعرفية لم نغادر
اللسان جيد فالتوصية بتجربته
لخفض النيران وخاصة التصريحات
وخاصة تمهيدا لتقديم تقرير إسرائيل إلى مجلس النواب
أما بالنسبة للشهر المقبل، فقد نشرنا هنا الليلة الماضية ما أوصيت به
المستوى المهني سيكون لإسرائيل للحفاظ على السلحفاة
أن المحكمة أصدرت لها وأنها سوف تقدم التقرير إلى المنزل
ومن ثم يحتاج القانون إلى توخي الحذر فيما يتعلق بالتصريحات بشكل أكبر
شيء قبل أن نتحدث عن الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة في المنزل
تورط القاضي باراك خلف الكواليس
خصم في إسرائيل كان له تأثير كبير هنا
ومن المهم بالنسبة للبروفيسور أهارون باراك أنه سيبقى في المركز الثاني
الأوامر التي ليست موطناً لإسرائيل على أية حال ومن ناحية أخرى
حتى أكثر القضاة عدائية لم يتوقفوا
القتال لقد حدث شيء ما خلف الأدوات خلال شهر واحد
حيث يتناوب بعض القضاة في المحكمة القادمة
قاضي من جنوب أفريقيا وهو ما يعني القاضي في القضية
سيصدر هذا ولن يقرر القضية بالفعل خلال شهر
التالي هو مناقشة مسألة أخرى ذات صلة
إلى إسرائيل